nebia is a revolutionary shower head
that saves you money by using
45 percent less water but with a stream
of water that's way more powerful
than what you get with other shower
heads to get 15
off go to nebia.com pacman and use the
code pacman
we actually have increasingly good news
to report
about what's happening with coronavirus
vaccination in the united states and in
some other countries but with most of
our audience in the us
we're going to look at u.s data today
and you would think everybody would be
thrilled about this but there's actually
some people who are
furious at the number of vaccinations
happening and the number of vaccinations
that will soon be taking place but we'll
get to that a little bit later in the
show
you might remember that last weekend not
this past weekend where we changed the
clocks but
last weekend we had a record seven
million or so vaccinations in three days
that was the best three-day period to
date
we blew that out of the water this past
weekend
with 8.8 million vaccines
injected on friday saturday and sunday
by far a new record now this does
include
what is essentially a massive dump of
vaccine data on
saturday it made it look like there were
four and a half million vaccinations
done
just on that day in reality there was a
change to the methodological data
and in reality that 4.5 million would be
kind of spread out over a few days which
is why we're saying
8.8 million vaccines
over three days now pushing us to an
average of about 2.4 million vaccines
per day over the last week
i think we're on the way to 2.5 million
a day i think we're on the way to 3
million a day the question is more will
we get to
three and a half or how much can we
really do
but this is looking increasingly good
right now
the states with the highest percentage
of people fully vaccinated are
alaska at 18 new mexico it's 17
south dakota and west virginia at 15
and then you've got a bunch of states at
14 a bunch more at 13
the state's doing the worst with
vaccination as a percentage of the
population are utah at only eight
percent
followed by washington d.c not a state i
know but it's still on our list
uh tennessee california georgia texas
and then you've got a few states at 10
now the reality is that with alaska and
new mexico as outliers
at at the very top the states doing
great are at 13 to 15 and the states
doing poorly
are at 8 to 11. so like the range is
relatively tight
and it has to do with a number of
different factors including
distribution of doses uh rural versus
urban nature of each state
and over time these numbers are going to
go up and they're going to go up more
quickly
now dr anthony fauci suggested over the
weekend on cnn
keep vaccinating as quickly as possible
but keep measures in place because some
of the things that are starting to
happen including in florida and other
spring break destinations
are not quite so good but let's take a
look the best way that we can avoid
any threat from variants is do two
things
get as many people vaccinated as quickly
as we possibly can
and to continue with the public health
measures
until we get this broad umbrella of
protection
over society that the level of infection
is very low
you know there's a tenet in virology
that's so
true jake and that is viruses don't
mutate
unless they replicate and replication
means it's spreading around
in the community if you can blunt that
you'll be blunting the evolution of
mutants for sure
so uh dr fauci of course absolutely
correct
and we'll talk about the spring break
stuff a little bit in a moment
what new information do we have about
the impact of vaccines well we know that
so far coronavirus cases have fallen
80 percent among u.s nursing home
staff and residents they were of the
first groups of people
to be vaccinated that's very good we
know we're heading to
full adult vaccine eligibility across
the united states
everyone 18 plus will be eligible for a
vaccine
a per joe biden's announcement on
thursday night
um on may 1st or sooner some states
ready to move even sooner that's just
six weeks away at the latest
that's fantastic we know thanks to
really detailed
israeli data that of the people recently
hospitalized there
only eight percent had been vaccinated
74 of those hospitalized had no vaccine
and the remainder about 18 were between
dose 1 and 2 not yet at full
vaccine power that is um
reassuring data but we also know
that tons of people are going nuts and
even
absent being vaccinated are starting to
ignore
all safety measures florida for example
becoming
an absolutely out of control spring
break situation with massless people
all over the place as if nothing is
going on now we that we shouldn't do
this this is a major problem
my guess is that if you start having
young people go nuts
but continue vaccinating those most at
risk you'll still get a ton of
cases but you should see fewer
hospitalizations and deaths because the
people going bonkers
on south beach are primarily younger
folks who will not
statistically get serious cases some
will and some will die though
um but the most uh the most moral the
most logical thing to do would be
let's keep up the guidelines for just a
little bit longer because we
are starting to get there case declines
have slowed down a bit
death declines continue to go relatively
quickly and we'll have updated numbers
about that tomorrow but what we have to
talk about next is
you would think there's no way to spin
more vaccinations
as anything other than a fantastic thing
but there are right-wingers
really angry at how many people are now
getting vaccinated
under the new protocol of the biden
administration and we're going to talk
about that next
so as we already we started the show
today talking about
the explosion of vaccination 8.8 million
vaccinations happening over this weekend
friday saturday sunday we are now uh
right around two and a half million
vaccinations per day
probably going higher this is not by
chance
this was exactly what joe biden ran on
doing
from before day one he put in place
infrastructure and a team
to increase vaccinations as quickly as
possible and it's happening
now a lot of people are insisting trump
trump trump credit for the vaccines we
will talk
in the next segment about why there's
really very little trump gets credit for
on the vaccines
he gets credit for not obviously
standing in the way
although downplaying the seriousness of
the virus
is making it so that half of trump
voters don't want the vaccine
so we'll talk about trump's role a
little bit later
but let's talk about joe biden on
thursday night joe biden told the nation
during his first primetime white house
address as president
which got higher ratings than trump's
first one and that seems to be highly
triggering to many
joe biden said he believes we have and
will have
enough supply for every state
to make all adults meaning 18 plus
eligible for vaccine appointments as of
may 1st
and many right wingers are absolutely
furious let's take it step by step
here's what joe biden said late last
week first
tonight i'm announcing that i will
direct all states
tribes and territories to make all
adults
people 18 and over eligible to be
vaccinated
no later than may 1. let me say that
again
all adult americans will be eligible to
get a vaccine
no later than may 1. this is a major
accomplishment say what you want about
biden on minimum wage
the stimulus taking too long not
managing the border situation well
enough i'm with you i've been on all of
those stories
but the way trump rolled out vaccination
we were thinking about maybe 18 plus by
september
maybe mid-august may 1st eligibility for
all adults is powerful and it is huge
joe biden also saying which triggered
the right very much
something optimistic that the way things
are going
we are likely to be able to have july
4th gatherings not necessarily
ragers with 500 people but gatherings
take a look at that
and finally fifth and maybe most
importantly
i promise i will do everything in my
power
i will not relent until we beat this
virus
but i need you the american people i
need you
i need every american to do their part
that's not hyperbole i need you i need
you to get vaccinated when it's your
turn and when you can find an
opportunity
and to help your family your friends
your neighbors
get vaccinated as well because here's
the point
if we do all this if we do our part
if we do this together by july the
fourth there's a good chance you
your families and friends will be able
to get together in your backyard or in
your neighborhood
and have a cookout at a barbecue and
celebrate independence day
that doesn't mean large events with lots
of people together but it does mean
small groups will be able to get
together without a doubt
joe biden's best speech and public event
so far
and the right is simply furious here is
right wing bomb
thrower mark levin considered an
intellectual to the modern reactionary
right-wing movement
calling this speech the most disgusting
speech
ever given by a politician
yeah this speech that joe biden gave
is the most disgusting propagandistic
speech that a demagogue even a
politician has ever given
it is pathetic just completely irate
about it here is laura ingram weighing
in with sean hannity calling the speech
a funeral for america what do you think
of this speech
well i think it was supposed to be
inspiring
it seemed a tad like a funeral for
america however
so that's my quick take
i don't even know if she saw the speech
from what she's saying a funeral for
america
after trump was vaccinating only about
850 000 a day
we did nearly 9 million in a weekend
we're opening vaccination to all adults
by may 1st
biden is saying we're going to have 4th
of july gatherings it's the opposite of
a funeral
they don't seem to like the good news
and then here is laura ingram
on her own excuse me on her own show
saying there is a double standard
because the left likes joe biden saying
july 4th looks good
but they didn't like donald trump saying
easter
of 2020 looks good last year
and she says there's a hypocrisy
because of this take a look well what
were the journalists saying their
reaction to this
pseudo science i think it was very
moving i thought it was really important
when he talked about that july 4th goal
he is the guy we need right now july 4th
you know he he put that on the calendar
as well so
right people are going to be looking at
their calendars now with some hope if we
all do our part by the fourth of july
we might be able to celebrate
independence day together which would be
incredible
i don't even know who that last person
was with the mask who was that
oh chris hayes okay now how is that
based in any science now i seem to
remember a different reaction from the
press corps
who were crucifying trump for pegging
reopening to a holiday
last spring president trump pushing the
country
to get up and running by easter but top
medical experts are warning
it is much much too soon we're going to
have everything lifted by easter
no the president saying i want the whole
world to be opened up by easter
and think about what bill gates just
said you do that too early and you're
going to be ignoring all the bodies in
the corner
oh my gosh i hadn't seen that until just
then
now of course the truth is the press was
acting
like the comms department for the dnc
last spring
laura the difference between trump
saying will be open by easter 2020
and biden saying small fourth of july
gatherings
is that it was ridiculous to talk about
easter of 2020.
there was never any chance of that
happening no
medical experts thought that was
possible it was a
joke it was laughable trump was again
the humiliation
globally of the united states when we
had just started
taking any measures in mid-march and
trump was saying in
april we're going to be wide open every
single one of those comments about
easter of 2020
was correct it was nutty to think of
opening in easter of 2020
and then laura ingraham and i think this
is really what makes them mad
laura ingram had a panel on which
someone named molly hemingway
said it's unamerican for joe biden to
say he might
allow gatherings on july 4th which is of
course not what he said take a look
again and then to pick independence day
as the day where
he says he might allow people to gather
is just
so un-american and and just you know
joe biden doesn't get to tell me when i
can have a barbecue in my backyard
and certainly not to tie that to
independence day and
of course people have been barbecuing
this entire time it's not a question of
permission
it's for those who pay attention to the
cdc
and what public health experts say the
way things are pointing
are we could safely do this it's not
about
permission it's about working together
and it continued all night and even into
the next day from that same night
sean hannity ran a headline called biden
should thank
trump for vaccine and i tweeted about
this
asking can anyone explain to me what
trump actually did on vaccination
any government would generally fund
research it's not special
are we supposed to thank him trump for
not going out of his way
to prevent vaccine development trump now
wants credit
for a vaccine he said we didn't actually
need
to end the pandemic to end a pandemic
that he said wasn't serious anyway
and the vaccine which he received in
private in january and kept a secret
until we learned last week that he had
been vaccinated which also doesn't
encourage people to go out and get
vaccinated
they are simply furious that this is
going well
per capita on vaccination rates it's
israel
the united arab emirates the uk and
chile
and then the united states we are in the
top five vaccinators in the world per
capita
the next countries down have done only
like a sixth of the vaccinations per
capita that we have
and the right can't take it part of by
the way
we're going to talk later about anthony
fauci's comments about
why aren't republicans wanting to get
vaccinated part of it is
they were told this wasn't serious for a
year part of it is
they believe that them getting
vaccinated helps joe biden
be able to say look at all the
vaccinations so i
expect them to keep this going probably
straight into the 2022 election and
we'll be covering it
through and until then next friday the
26th
we are running a massive one-day
membership promo
why well the reason why isn't the best
it's that february was our worst month
in terms of memberships in over a year
a lot of people hit with financial
trouble february only 28 days
less time for people to sign up
disastrous month for us so fr
next friday the 26th we're doing a
membership blowout
it'll be a sort of vaccination related
coupon code
if you want to be notified just get on
my mailing list
at davidpakman.com and you'll get an
email bright and early next friday
morning
one of our sponsors today is nebia the
creator of the world's most
innovative shower head it uses only
about
half the water that other shower heads
do saving you money helping the
environment
but it's actually a lot more powerful
than other shower heads on the market it
has twice the coverage of other shower
heads
the water sprays with a ton of pressure
i've been using it in my bathroom at
home
i love it only took a few minutes to set
up really easy and it's been a totally
different
experience than any other shower head
i've used i can get in and out of the
shower way quicker now
because of how powerful it is it only
takes a few seconds to get
completely rinsed off so i was actually
amazed that it's only using about half
as much
water nebia also offers a number of
shower accessories like shelves and
curtains which match
perfectly with the design of the shower
head the shower head starts at just
199 but the first hundred people to go
to nebia.com
and use code pacman will get 15
off all nebia products the david pakman
show
is funded and supported by listeners and
viewers
just like you i've seen them they are
they really are just like you
and you can sign up at joinpacman.com
the coupon code better21 will save you
a bundle let's just put it that way and
you'll get the daily world famous bonus
show
sign up at joinpackman.com
there's a new uh sort of um enlightened
centrist hot take which is okay
biden's doing well on vaccinations now
but it's all built on the system that
donald trump and his administration
built
and that couldn't be further from the
truth
there's a good article in talking points
memo
by kate rega and josh kavinsky which
says
you know the washington post is doing
this the new york times is doing this
they're saying
that the speed up we are seeing now
builds on the trump plan and it is
simply wrong
kate and josh do a deep dive into what
was actually happening in the trump
administration during the last few
months
and in fact it's stunning at how well
joe biden has been able to expand
vaccination
despite donald trump's actions there was
no plan left behind
biden and his team had to build the plan
from day one
for how to get the vaccines once they
were dumped at states
to places that are actually vaccinating
established vaccination sites and the
like
uh there even when given the opportunity
on supply joe biden has had to fix the
problems that donald trump left behind
including trump famously turning down
100 million doses of pfizer back in july
of 2020
maybe because pfizer wasn't
participating in operation warp speed
that left joe biden to figure out how
can we actually get enough vaccines for
people
and now we will have enough vaccines
where on may first we will be opening
eligibility to
everybody 18 plus in the united states
every aspect of what donald trump did
was counterproductive other than
what we could say here's the praise we
could give of donald trump
beyond all the things he did to stifle
us having enough vaccines and reduce
interest in vaccination
trump didn't actively deny funding
to companies developing vaccines and
that's barely praise
and i know that one of the things you
heard
there were two things that were
repeatedly mentioned during the trump
era that trump was doing one is
he's funding vaccine research just about
every country was funding vaccine
research
in the middle of a global pandemic what
government wouldn't fund research to
some degree
to say that trump deserves praise for
that
if he didn't do it it would have been
criminal now many of the companies
researching vaccines didn't take the
money
or they didn't need the money but to say
trump funded stuff i mean listen the
government
funds endless things and to say that's
why he gets credit
is very low now the other thing is you
know trump tells the story of how
they came to me they said sir let's fund
manufacture of vaccines even before we
know these vaccines are going to be
effective and the ones to use
this has been widely done across the
world for decades when you have an
urgent situation and you have a vaccine
or a medication that
looks like it will work but it's still
being tested you don't want to waste
time you want doses ready to go
if and when it gets approved so what you
do is you manufacture vaccines on spec
you start manufacturing a bunch of
different candidates
so that if they get approved you already
have some doses
trump did fund that i guess he gets
credit for that now what about on the
other side what did he do
to hurt the vaccine effort well number
one when you say it's not serious for a
year
and that it's being exaggerated by the
left and that all aspects of this start
to take away your freedom and all of
this stuff
that reduces people's interest in
getting vaccinated because why would i
get vaccinated for something my dear
leader trump has been telling me isn't
serious
for a year number two trump's own
vaccination
happened while he was still in office in
secret
and we only learned about it in the last
week or so
because it leaked that is not something
you do if you're trying to get more
people interested in getting the vaccine
number three trump declined doses when
they were
offered by pfizer in july of 2020 as i
mentioned
again maybe mad because they weren't
part of operation warp speed
and it left us with a a need for joe
biden to figure out where to get more
doses so
i'm sorry guys trump doesn't deserve
credit for vaccines
trump was to some degree
just not a factor in that he allowed
money to go
towards some vaccine research and did
some things that decreased interest in
the vaccine
and handed off no plan to joe biden he
he could have more aggressively hurt the
cause
but trump doesn't deserve credit for
these vaccines and what we are seeing
now in terms of the rollout in the
expansion
was a plan that joe biden started
building in december
knowing what he was coming into and and
joe biden
has not joe biden there's lots of things
he doesn't deserve praise for right now
which i've criticized him for
this is joe biden's thing he put in
place a parallel coronavirus task force
back in december
they started figuring this out when they
took over there was no plan they built
the plan they secured doses from
a jnj they got additional doses lined up
from modern up from pfizer
this really is biden's thing and it
seems pretty clear that
uh voters realize that but for some
reason
dr anthony fauci is baffled by what's
going on and i want to talk about that
uh next dr anthony fauci did a bunch of
interviews over the weekend he did one
with
jake tapper on cnn he did an interview
with chris wallace on a fox news and
some other interviews and one of the
things that we learned last week based
on a new poll
is that 49 percent of uh is it 49 of
republicans are male
republicans 49 of one or the other
don't want the vaccine and 47 percent of
all trump voters
don't want the vaccine and dr anthony
fauci said on tv
with chris wallace that he does not get
it
let's take a listen to what he had to
say according to
a recent poll 49 percent of republican
men
said they don't intend to get the
vaccine
doctor how much of a difference will it
make if president
trump who was largely responsible for
the success of operation warp speed
how much of a difference will it make if
president trump leads a campaign
for the people who are most devoted to
him to actually go out and get the
vaccine
chris i think it would make all the
difference in the world he's a
very widely popular person among
republicans
if he came out and said go and get
vaccinated it's really important
for your health the health of your
family and the health of the country
it seems absolutely inevitable that the
vast majority of people
who are his close followers would listen
to him he's such a strongly popular
person i cannot imagine
that if he comes out that they would not
get vaccinated would be very
helpful to the effort for that to happen
i'm very surprised
at the high percentage of republicans
who say they don't want to get
vaccinated i don't understand
where that's coming from this is not a
political issue
so dr fauci uh doesn't seem to get that
for a lot of these people
it is a political issue and it's a
political issue in two ways as i
mentioned
earlier if for a year you were told this
isn't really
serious why would you want to get a
vaccine
and just as importantly because it is
political to them
as we now start to see we were
vaccinating 800
000 a day under trump we got to a
million a day which is what biden
promised
we got to a million and a half we got to
2 million a day
we're now at 2.4 million a day and we're
going to three and maybe we're going to
3.5
they see that this is an accomplishment
of joe biden i think some of them simply
don't want to participate
in part of being of in being part of
that that number
that is a number increasingly attributed
to what joe biden has been able to do
so anthony fauci you know maybe he's
sincere
in saying he's baffled i think he's sort
of playing coy i think he understands
perfectly
why it is that this number of people are
not interested in the vaccine
and it is exactly because of what we saw
the trump administration do
for a full year uh dr fauci also
appeared on nbc news he was asked about
the exact same data and
he again said it makes absolutely no
sense it makes no sense medically
it makes no sense in terms of being a
team player
it makes no sense economically because
the thing that's going to recover the
economy the most quickly
is going to be getting as many people as
vaccinated as possible so that we really
can turn this into something that most
people won't get at all
and almost everyone who does get it if
vaccinated
does not get serious covet it could
reduce deaths to
almost none if we had everyone
vaccinated
and um it is it you know other kind
there there are vaccine skeptical
movements
in many countries but the way
in which simply being a trumpist has
completely
weaponized anti-vaxx in a way that's
divorced from the normal stuff like
normal anti-vaxx as we talked about last
week
is often based on for the left
skepticism of big
pharma and on the right skepticism of
government telling them what it is they
have to do
this goes very much beyond that and this
goes to the
competing narratives that existed the
science-based narrative mostly supported
by democrats about what it is that
should be done about a serious pandemic
and the non-science-based narrative
supported by trump
and many people around him sometimes
explicitly sometimes
implicitly about this is like the flu 15
cases will go to zero
what about injecting bleach well fauci
initially said don't wear masks so
what about that and all of the things
that we've seen
and this is the simply the logical
conclusion you see it in the partisan
divide
of who it is that wants to get
vaccinated and unfortunately
i've said before you're not going to get
everybody vaccinated
but if you have half of republicans
unwilling to get vaccinated that
actually
will lead to people dying uh either
because they can't get vaccinated in
some cases and because the vaccines
aren't 100
and it'll really uh take take a a chunk
out
of us getting to herd immunity so it's
not a viable number more than 50 percent
of trump voters
are going to have to get vaccinated if
we are to reach full herd immunity and
we may not
um there is no indication the government
is going to force anybody to get
vaccinated
but if increasingly um
venues businesses airlines say after a
certain date
you know may 1 there's going to be full
availability eligibility for vaccination
you may start seeing airlines and
concert venues and sporting events
say as of i don't know october 1
november 1 in order to come to an event
with us in order to fly with us or
whatever you need proof of vaccination
i think that that the sort of practical
reality of that
may be what pushes more of these
republicans to ultimately get vaccinated
let me know what you think am i wrong
will they say well
if jetblue requires vaccination i'm
never flying jetblue will they go that
route
i don't know we'll be following this
story on instagram
at davidpakmanshow and you can follow me
on instagram
at david.pacman as well
the number one funding source for the
david pakman show
has been and continues to be membership
and membership is not just a feel-good
thing you get access to the world famous
bonus show
every single day just for members as
well as commercial free
audio and video feeds of the show
day in and day out you can sign up for
membership very very
quickly at joinpackman.com that's
join pakman.com
if the normal prices strike you as high
by
all means use the coupon code better21
all one word all lowercase become a
member today
all right this is sort of like an aside
kind of adding insult to injury type
story
uh one thing that's become clear in the
first couple months of joe biden's
presidency is that he truly doesn't seem
to care about
a lot of these vanity elements that were
very important to the former president
things like
television ratings or joe biden's
signature being on the coveted relief
checks that are starting to go out now
and we know that those things were very
very important to donald trump and yet
joe biden's first primetime national
address on thursday night during which
he announced
every adult will be eligible for a
vaccine by may 1st in all 50 states
that biden event got higher ratings and
more viewership than donald trump's
first address as president
about 18.2 million people watched joe
biden's speech on broadcast networks
compared to donald trump's first one
which 17.7 million viewers watched about
half a million more people watched the
joe biden event than watched the donald
trump event and the best part about this
to me is that joe biden clearly doesn't
care
about any of it but it's also
particularly funny because one of donald
trump's main
campaign lines against joe biden was
there's just no energy around joe i show
up and do huge rallies and joe had 10
people in cars there
honking and of course this was by design
joe biden because of the pandemic
decided it wouldn't be responsible to do
what donald trump was doing
and that's the explanation we also know
as we
learned from the democratic primary as
much as we did from the general election
in november
that tweets and facebook posts and rally
crowds don't necessarily tell you who
actually has
more support in reality and joe biden
got millions more votes than donald
trump
but biden ends up without even caring
kind of beating donald trump at his own
game without even playing the game if
you can imagine that
and as much as we know donald trump is
upset about joe biden getting credit for
the vaccination rollout which donald
trump you might remember last week put
out a statement saying please
remember that i should get credit
for the vaccines as much as trump is
upset
that things are actually starting to
improve
finally on the virus what makes
trump really upset is that he's not
getting attention anymore
and joe biden is and as hilarious
as it is that joe biden got better
ratings than trump
it's something that trump is primarily
the one who cares about
the biden administration hasn't even
talked about this fact because it really
doesn't seem biden cares about ratings
and marks so to speak
and you can tell from the reactions from
right wingers
that we looked at earlier in the show
that they are
also struggling with how to respond some
right-wingers have decided to focus in
on joe biden has dementia
he seemed demented during his speech he
didn't even know where he was during the
speech during which he announced hey
guys
we're accelerating vaccinations so much
that by may 1st
every adult will be eligible for a
vaccine they couldn't they didn't want
to focus on the substance so instead
they said oh joe joe biden didn't even
know he was at the white house during
the speech
others focused on how dare
joe biden politicize the 4th of july
by saying we will probably be able to
have safe
cookouts and barbecues on july 4th
others focused on how dare joe biden not
get down
on his knees and pray to trump for
creating the vaccines that biden is now
rolling out
and of course earlier we said trump
really doesn't deserve any credit for
the vaccines
and then other right-wingers have
focused on fear-mongering
about joe biden expanding vaccination
this month
is a clear pretext for forcing everybody
to get vaccinated which
obviously is not going to happen
and it's not what the administration is
doing it was
just like a good simple political speech
with joe biden communicating vaccination
is improving significantly it will
continue improving
and every aspect of that speech has the
right
absolutely furious and then more people
watching it than the number of people
that watch donald trump's first address
is just kind of like a pile on
at this point but there's an interesting
story to the ratings
that goes beyond trump's obsession with
ratings
when every presidential speech was like
out of this world wacky cartoonish for
four straight years
a normal speech has actually become sort
of interesting
people wrote to me dozens of people
saying you know
it wasn't that i watched the biden
speech with you or on a network or
wherever
because i expected fireworks i didn't
most people didn't even expect the
expansion of vaccination to 18 plus by
may 1st
people basically wrote to me and said i
wanted to see a president just kind of
behave normally
communicate in a normal way what is
going on and that
it might get tougher before it gets
better and joe biden even sang
if this doesn't go as well as we're
hoping for i'm going to tell you
i'm not going to lie to you and say it
all went well if it didn't go well
and there's been an absence of that in
the united states for four years and i
think that's
as big a part um of what we are seeing
in terms of
these tv ratings for for the biden event
um
as anything else i want to kind of close
the loop on that explosive story from
last week
last week i notified you that there is
another call that now is playing a role
in the investigation taking place in
georgia another call
in which donald trump called the
investigator in the secretary of state's
office in georgia
again to talk about i need a couple
thousand votes and
there was a lot of wrongdoing and we won
by a lot
and we won this by a lot and all of
these different statements
that call which we learned about last
week we have now
learned was found in a
trash folder on the computer device
of a state investigator which raises new
questions about whether there was an
effort made
to actually suppress the fact that that
phone call took place
cnn reports that discovery of the call
came after state officials originally
said they didn't think
audio of the call existed and it turns
out
that it did exist it was in the trash
folder
of an investigator involved in this
and it is the uh recording in which
trump
pushes on the investigator francis
watson
claims of widespread voter fraud and
trying to influence the investigation
and subsequently really trying to
overturn the results in georgia
so that the electoral votes in georgia
would go to trump instead of to joe
biden
the audio file is from a december 23
call we listened to it last week
and the call is between trump and
investigator francis watson
it was discovered as the georgia
secretary of state's office
was responding to a public records
request the washington post
first reported the details of how the
audio
emerged watson was asked did you delete
this
why did you delete it why was it in that
folder
it was uncovered only due to a foia
request did you plan to come forward and
say this exists because
there's a big difference if you're an
investigator between saying
hey i have this call versus hitting
delete and relegating it to your recycle
bin presumably for future deletion now
of course
we could say you know if she really
meant to eliminate the record
she would have cleared the recycle bin i
assumed that by
a full a folder of deleted files they're
talking about a recycle bin or
equivalent
it's all very very strange and cnn
previously reported
that in that december phone call that's
at issue trump was
urging her to find ways to give him
georgia and saying she would be praised
if she were able to overturn those
results
and uh we now are going to have to see
what the the meaning and significance is
of this
last week the bombshell was the call
trump made to brad raffensberger
wasn't the only call to georgia
officials before the call to brad
raffensberger
trump actually called francis watson and
said much of the same which is wow this
so now we know this was not a one-off
call this was a series of scheduled
phone calls
now we learn that we learned of the
audio
because of a foia request and it was in
a deleted files folder
on francis watson's computer which
starts to change
maybe the course of this investigation
where maybe the investigators
actually need to be investigated so it's
getting increasingly complex
inclu increasingly muddied and and i
asked this question
i'm not saying this rhetorically are
there
investigators in georgia that can
actually
really investigate this objectively um
the you know brad raffensberger's office
the secretary of state
they're clearly not the right place
because they are participants in all of
this brad raffensberger was the one
trump called to try to influence on the
results
so we know about investigator francis
watson but now we learned francis watson
had deleted audio
of the call and it was in the recycle
bin or something equivalent to it so
that's probably not the right person to
investigate how it ended up there so so
who exactly needs to be brought in
do you need some kind of special
investigator do federal authorities need
to come in do they would they have
jurisdiction i don't know
uh but this needs to be figured out
because this is just georgia
but every week we are learning more that
makes
that raises more questions rather than
answering them
about exactly how um planned
and uh coordinated was this effort to
try to overturn the georgia results
there's also now emails that have come
out
referencing upcoming phone calls with
donald trump's then chief of staff mark
meadows
in georgia which again suggests the
phone calls were happening but the phone
calls involving trump were happening
after other preparatory phone calls were
already made
this may have been a much larger effort
to after the fact try to steal georgia
from joe biden
hopefully we'll we'll learn the full
scope of it at some point in time
we're going to take a quick break
stunning video from senator ron johnson
coming up after the break and we will
also talk about this is strange
the announcement of urination on fox
news i know it sounds crazy but we'll
talk about it after the break
the david pakman show is audience
supported media and you can contribute
any amount you want on patreon as little
as one dollar per month
plus you can get the daily bonus show
world famous at this point
and the daily commercial free tv show
by making those pledges at patreon.com
slash david pakman show this is audience
supported media we depend on the support
of our viewers and listeners
whether you listen to the podcast watch
on youtube or watch
us on tv or even listen on the radio
patreon.com
davidpakmanshow this story is absolutely
fascinating and there's so much
that we can discuss but we should really
kind of start
with with a clip and one of the really
kind of lightweight when it comes to you
know intellectually
one of the really lightweight republican
senators out there is a guy named ron
johnson he represents
wisconsin and he's gone completely off
the deep end in the past for example
during a recent congressional hearing
about the january 6th riots he suggested
that the insurrectionists weren't
really trump supporters but it was some
combination
of provocateurs and fake trump
supporters and we're going to get to
that because it exposes his obvious lies
in a moment
but i want to start with a clip of ron
johnson recently going on the joe pags
radio show i don't know if this is an
online show or like a broadcast radio
but he went on this show and he said he
didn't feel threatened ron johnson
didn't feel threatened during the
january 6th riots now you might say well
why
why didn't he feel threatened if if they
were you know provocateurs and
antifa or whoever that should be
threatening to him as a republican right
well no
he says he didn't feel threatened
because the rioters
were pro-trump people who love the
country but
had they been black lives matter had
they been antifa
he might have been afraid take a look at
this clip this white supremacist
they don't really believe that but they
know there's a percentage of those that
they're telling that that will believe
it that's really the game right i mean
there's no way people you go to work
with every day really think
that you and i are white supremacists
because we believe in conservative
values right
well no and let's face it i'm also
criticized because i've made the comment
that
on january 6 i never felt threatened
because i
didn't and mainly because i knew that
even though
those thousands of people that were
marching to the capitol
were trying to pressure people like me
to vote the way they wanted me to vote
i knew those are people that love this
country that uh
truly respect law enforcement would
never do anything to to break a law
and so i wasn't concerned now had the
tables been turned joe this got me in
trouble
had the tables been turned and president
trump
won the election and those were tens of
thousands of black lives matter and
antifa
protesters i might have been a little
concerned wow
that's a big statement but you know it's
a true statement we see the recent
history
well let's face it you know people
didn't board up their store fronts in in
metropolitan areas
in case joe biden won and now you take a
look at what's happening in minneapolis
the trial so there are just a ton of
things there to talk about now first of
all
it's hard to hear him say that and not
get the sense that he sort of means i
wasn't scared because the protesters
were white which of course
they were almost exclusively white if it
had been black people
under the banner of black lives matter
or antifa then i would have been scared
he does stop just short of saying that
so i'm sort of inferring i
admit i'm speculating it has that
feeling he doesn't actually say it so
let's not focus too much on that
the part that's hilarious is that in
this interview
ron johnson says i wasn't scared because
the protesters
were trump people who loved the country
and wanted the election overturned
they're on his side so to speak but
during the recent congressional
testimony
he used his question and answer time to
suggest
that they were not really trump
supporters on january 6th
but they were fake trump supporters this
was just a couple of weeks ago remember
this clip those people i passed or who
passed me along constitution avenue some
were indignant
and contemptuous of congress but not one
appeared angry or incited to riot
many of the marchers were families with
small children many were elderly
overweight or just plain tired or frail
traits not typically attributed to the
riot prone many were pro police shirts
or carried pro police black and blue
flags
although the crowd represented a broad
cross section of americans mostly
working class by their appearance and
manner of speech
some people stood out a very few didn't
share the jovial friendly earnest
demeanor of the great majority
some obviously didn't fit in and he
describes
four different types of people
plainclothes militants
agents provocateurs fake trump
protesters
and then disciplined uniform column of
attackers i think these are the people
that
probably plan this so are you noticing
the absurdity of this
in february during the hearings about
trump supporters who did the riots ron
johnson floats the idea they weren't
really trump supporters
they were fake trump supporters they
were provocateurs but
now he's asked in an interview did you
feel threatened he says
why would i feel threatened these are
just people who love america and they
wanted me to vote a certain way
they wanted me to object to the
electoral account wait a second ron
two weeks ago you said they weren't real
trump supporters
now you say they are and that's why you
didn't feel threatened how can both
possibly be true
which one does he actually believe i
think we know which one
i think he believes they were trump
supporters and he was super comfortable
with the fascist authoritarian rioters
who were seeking to overturn the
election
because they're on his side had they
been anti-fascist
protesters he would have been very very
scared and you tell me whether you think
that that's ideology-based
or race-based or whatever the case may
be a disgusting guy
never fails to impress that upon me and
this is just one example
of i actually believe there's two layers
to this
when elected officials like this guy
talk about they might have been
fake trump supporters i don't think any
of them believe it
when they talk about antifa was spotted
or
uh the no real it's a no true scotsman
fallacy
no real trump supporter would riot
therefore anyone rioting could not have
been a trump supporter
i don't think the elected officials
believe it for a second but
unfortunately
a lot of their constituents do and i've
seen
some people i went to high school with i
went to a very uh diverse high school
ideologically so to speak um
people i went to high school with i've
seen genuinely posting on facebook that
they believe it was antifa in disguise
they don't believe that they were actual
trump supporters that it was antifa in
disguise
that got all the trump flags and the
trump hats and first went to the rally
and also posted on facebook for weeks
that they were going to be there and
their entire facebook persona was staged
to look like
some people really fell for this
obviously false notion so
when ron johnson floated it two weeks
ago three weeks ago
i didn't really believe he believed it
uh now
it becomes very clear and uh truly
just a bottom feeder disgusting
disgusting guy
hey this is a funny story this is not
like uh
mind-blowingly newsworthy but for some
reason i love this
fox news seems to increasingly be having
all sorts of technical problems where
people don't know that they're on the
air
their monitors go haywire they can't
hear things part of it might be
might be uh due to um
some sort of socially distanced
productions that are going on where
people are in different locations
during one of their shows they come back
from commercial and this guy greg
gutfeld
who's tweeted to me in the past started
singing about how he has to go to the
bathroom and host juan williams
starts a statement gutfeld just sings
over him that he has to pee
and people try to tell him we're live
right now we're on the air
it doesn't seem to matter and then
another host jesse waters makes the most
forced laugh i've maybe ever heard
to pretend that this isn't completely
humiliating take a look
time now for one more thing i got a p
i got a p
you're on the air
great greg
jesse why aren't you saying you kicked
us off
that was so funny all right um i'll take
greg's slot until he has to come back
from the bathroom
i want everybody to watch fox news this
weekend i need you to start
what a time to be alive isn't it now i
actually have some thoughts
about this that might be a different
interpretation a few viewers have been
emailing me over the last couple of
weeks and they've been saying
sir no they said david i watch
this show on fox news with juan williams
and greg gutfeld
and i keep thinking that gutfeld
hates juan williams and is deliberately
shunning him on air and for example they
sent me a clip from the other day when
juan williams was talking
and gutfeld was just looking down acting
like he was like on his phone and not
even listening to what williams was
saying
is it possible that in this clip gutfeld
could hear everything
fine and he knew he was on the air but
he just wanted to mess with william's
teleprompter read like i i have no idea
if that's what happened
but i'm wondering merely because so many
viewers wrote to me and said gutfeld
treats williams horribly on this show
to be honest this is the most
interesting thing that greg gutfeld has
ever said anywhere
i've never seen him be more compelling
and interesting than he was announcing
bodily functions that he needed to
participate in uh his normal screeds are
quite boring and uninteresting and
predictable
this was arguably the most coherent
moment greg gutfeld has ever had he
needs to urinate
he came across crystal clear i get what
he's saying i understand exactly what he
means arguably the most that he's
contributed to a segment on fox news in
years so
that's fox news continued technical
issues maybe
if you believe that that's what happened
we have a voicemail number and that
number is 219
to david p here's a question that
i can't tell if it's good faith or not
but there's a lot of meaty policy
discussion that we can have as a result
take a look at this question
hey david it's troll man the
anti-intellectual i have a question for
you
right why do democrats insist on having
medicare for all when the medical
industry
is more concerned with treating symptoms
with medications instead of addressing
the underlying cause
i'd like to hear your thought about that
so you know
the the fact that they call themselves
troll man the anti-intellectual makes me
think maybe this is not someone who's
actually contacting me
in good faith but these are good
questions one of the real problems with
the medical industry
and there's there's two different
reasons for this is that
the overwhelming focus is on symptoms
and and immediate causes rather than
maybe underlying causes and this
applies to you know so many different
conditions caused by obesity or a
sedentary lifestyle
or whatever the case may be that's a
problem and one of the things
that can be done to resolve that issue
is to go
sorry there's one other part of the
problem which is for the most part
uh doctors are paid for doing things to
the patient
you get paid or someone gets paid um
payments happen for ordering tests for
doing procedures
etc rather than how healthy can we keep
this person
so that they don't need as much medical
care
as we might be able to sign them up for
there
are some insurance co-ops and in certain
states there are
systems being developed where doctors
are compensated
for keeping people healthy rather than
for the number of things that they order
be done but the question is an
interesting one because
what he seems to be saying is that's how
the system works
if you do medicare for all that issue
just gets worse
no no no no one of the ideas of medicare
for all whether it's a national medicare
for all
or a state-run medicare for all is that
you could actually
change reimbursement policy and payment
systems
so that you start rewarding doctors for
keeping patients healthy
rather than reimbursing them based on
how many different tests and procedures
can you order
so there are two different issues and it
does not follow logically
that medicare for all would simply mean
an exacerbation
of the broken system that we now have um
and it's important when
assuming that that was a good faith
question and maybe i'm silly for for
assuming that
uh these these are two different things
and i would argue that the issue
of treating symptoms and profiting from
doing stuff
could be more easily fixed under a
medicare for all
uh system and it's been widely studied
and and we
we've talked about it before on the
bonus show today
kentucky's senate has voted to make it a
crime
to taunt or insult law enforcement
officers will this be made law and what
are the implications
and are there actual free speech
implications so often when the right
says
that's a first amendment violation has
nothing to do with the government
what about this we're going to talk
about that on the bonus show number two
spain is going to launch a trial of a
four-day
working week not the whole country but
in spain there is a trial and we've been
interested in this topic for some time
we're going to talk about it
and capitol police for all of the people
asking
how long is the national guard going to
be in dc how long are these fences going
to be up capitol police is now
moving forward on a plan to remove the
outer fence
and to make other security changes and
hopefully assuming
it's safe to do so that security
presence in washington dc is going to
start being diminished and we're
going to talk about it's become highly
politicized there's a lot of political
implications uh uh
to what is going on there um and the
right has been
bomb throwing quite a bit about national
guard in dc
seemingly forgetting that the reason the
national guard is there is because of
what the right did
on january 6th so all of those stories
and more on today's bonus show get
instant access by
signing up at joinpakman.com you can
also get access by making a five dollar
a month
or greater pledge on patreon at
patreon.com
davidpakmanshow i will see you then or
otherwise back on tomorrow's show
thanks a lot for watching today's show i
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors
nebia is a revolutionary shower head
that saves you money by using
45 percent less water but with a stream
of water that's way more powerful
than what you get with other shower
heads to get 15 percent off
go to nebia.com pacman and use the code
pacman